can we upset more people a little bit
you already i thought maybe we'd have to
try no no can we uh can i ask you
to elaborate because i my intuition was
that you would be a supporter of
something like cryptocurrency and
bitcoin because it is fundamentally
emphasizes decentralization what do you
so can you elaborate
yeah okay look your thoughts on bitcoin
i um
it's kind of funny um i i wrote
i've been advocating some kind of
digital currency for a long time and
when the the uh
when when bitcoin came out and the
original paper on on blockchain
um my heart kind of sank because i
thought oh my god we're applying all of
this fancy thought and all these very
careful distributed security measures to
recreate the gold standard
like it's just so retro it's so
dysfunctional it's so useless from an
economic point of view so it's always
and then the other thing is using
computational inefficiency at a
boundless scale as your form of security
is a crime against the atmosphere
obviously a lot of people know that now
but we knew that at the start like the
thing is when the first paper came out i
remember a lot of people saying oh my
god i think this thing scales it's a
carbon disaster you know
and and um
i i just like i'm just mystified but
that that's a different question than
when you ask can you have
um a cryptographic currency or at least
some kind of digital currency that's of
a benefit and absolutely like i'm and
there are people who are trying to be
thoughtful about this you should uh if
you haven't you should interview vitalik
budder in some time yeah you're probably
interviewing twice okay so like there
are people in the community who are
trying to be thoughtful and trying to
figure out how to do this better it has
nice properties though right so the one
of the nice problems is that like
government centralized it's hard to
control
uh and then the other one to fix some of
the issues that you're referring to i'm
sort of playing devil's advocate here is
you know there's lightning network
there's ideas how to how you uh build
stuff on top of bitcoin similar with
gold that allow you to have this kind of
vibrant economy that operates not on the
blockchain but outside the blockchain
and uses uh bitcoin for uh
for like checking the security of those
transactions so bitcoin's not new it's
been around for a while
i've been watching it closely i've i've
not seen one example of it creating
economic growth
there was this obsession with the idea
that government was the problem that
idea that government's the problem
let's say government earned that wrath
honestly
because if you look at some of the
things that governments have done in
recent decades it's not a pretty story
like
after
after a very small number of people in
the u.s government decided to bomb and
land mine
southeast asia
it's hard to come back and say oh
government's this great thing but
uh then
the problem is that this resistance to
government
is basically resistance to politics it's
a way of saying if i can get rich nobody
should bother me it's a way of not of
not having obligations to others and
that ultimately is a very suspect
motivation but does that mean
that the impulse that the government
should not overreach its power is flawed
well i mean what i want to ask you to do
is to replace the word government with
politics like our politics is people
having to deal with each other
my theory about freedom
is that the only authentic form of
freedom is perpetual annoyance that all
right so
annoyance means you're actually dealing
with people because people are annoying
perpetual means that that annoyance is
survivable so it doesn't destroy us all
so if you have perpetual annoyance then
you have freedom and that's politics
that's politics if you don't have
perpetual annoyance
something's gone very wrong and you
suppress those people it's only
temporary it's going to come back and be
horrible
you should seek perpetual annoyance i'll
invite you to a berkeley city council
meeting so you can know what that feels
like what perfection feels
like but anyway so freedom is being the
the test of freedom is that you're
annoyed by other people if you're not
you're not free if you're not you're
trapped in some temporary illusion
that's going to fall apart
now um the this quest to avoid
government is really a quest to avoid
that political feeling but you have to
have it you have to deal with it
and it sucks but that's the human
situation that's the human condition and
this idea that we're going to have this
abstract thing that protects us from
having to deal with each other is always
an illusion the idea and i apologize i
uh overstretched the use of the word
government
the idea is there should be some
punishment from the people
when a group when a bureaucracy when a
set of one instead of people or a
particular leader like in an
authoritarian regime which more than
half the world currently lives under if
you
[Music]
like if they
become
they start stop representing the people
it stops being like a berkeley uh
meeting and starts being more like uh
like a dictatorial kind of uh situation
and so the point is it it's nice to give
people
uh the populace and in decentralized way
power to
um
resist that kind of uh government
becoming over yeah but people see this
idea that the problem is always the
government being powerful is false
the problem can also be criminal gangs
the problem can also be weird cults the
problem can be
abusive
abusive clergy the problem can be uh
fault infrastructure that fails the
problem can be poisoned water the
problem can be failed electric grids the
problem can be
um
a crappy education system that makes
this the whole society uh less and less
able to to create value there are all
these other problems that are different
from an overbearing government like you
have to keep some sense of perspective
and not be obsessed with only one kind
of problem because then the others will
pop up but empirically speaking some
problems are bigger than others so like
some
uh like
groups of people like governments or
gangs or companies leaders are you are
you a u.s citizen yes has the government
ever really been a problem for you well
okay so first of all i grew up in the
soviet union used to use well and
actually yeah my wife did too
yeah so i i have i have seen you know um
sure uh
and has the government bothered me i
would say that
uh that's that's a really complicated
question especially because the united
states is such
it's a special place in like like like a
lot of other countries my wife's family
were refused next and so we have like a
very and uh her dad was sent to the
gulag uh for what it's worth uh on my
father's side all but a few were killed
by a pogrom in in uh
uh post-soviet program in ukraine
so i i think cause you did a little
trick of uh
eloquent trick of language that you
switched to the united states to talk
about government so
i am
i'm i believe unlike my friend michael
malus who's an anarchist
i believe
government can do a lot of good in the
world that is exactly what you're saying
which is it's it's politics the thing
that bitcoin folks and cryptocurrency
folks argue is that one of the big ways
that governments can control the
populace centralized bank like
controlled the
the money that was the case in the
soviet union too there's
you know uh inflation is can really make
poor people
suffer and
so what they argue is this is one way to
go around
that power that government has
uh of controlling the monetary system so
that's a way to resist that's not
actually
saying government bad that's saying
some of the ways that uh
central banks get into trouble can be
resisted through distractions so let me
ask you on balance today in the real
world in terms of actual facts
do you think cryptocurrencies are doing
more to prop up corrupt murderous
horrible regimes or to resist those
regimes where do you think the balance
is right now i i know exactly uh having
talked to a lot of cryptocurrency folks
what they would tell me right i
it's hard it's
i don't no no no no i'm asking it as a
real question there's no way to know the
answer that there's no way
perfectly however i gotta say uh if you
look at people who've been able to
decode
uh blockchains and they they do leak a
lot of data they're not as secure as
this widely thought
there are a lot of unknown uh bitcoin
whales from pretty early and they're
huge and
if you ask who are these people
um
there's evidence that a lot of them are
quite on not the people you'd want to
support let's say and
i i just don't like i think empirically
this idea
that there's some intrinsic way that bad
governments will
be
what will be
disempowered and people will be able to
resist them more than new villains or
even villainous governments will be
empowered there's no basis for that
assertion it just is kind of
circumstantial
and uh
i think in general
bitcoin ownership
is one thing but bitcoin transactions
have tended to support criminality more
than
productivity of course they would argue
that was that was the story of its early
days that now more and more
bitcoin is being used for uh legitimate
transactions but that's the difference i
didn't say for legitimate transactions i
said for economic growth for for
creativity like um
i uh i think what's happening is people
are using it a little bit for
for buying i don't know maybe somebody's
companies make it available for this and
that they buy a tesla with it or
something yeah um
investing in a startup
hard
it might have happened a little bit but
it's it's not an engine of productivity
creativity and economic growth
uh whereas old-fashioned currency still
is and
uh anyway i'm look i think something
i'm i'm pro the idea of digital
currencies yeah
i am anti
the idea
of
economics
wiping out politics as a result i think
they have to exist in some balance to
avoid the worst dysfunctions of each
in some ways there's parallels to our
discussion of algorithms and
cryptocurrency is you're pro the idea
but it can be used
uh to manipulate you can use be used
poorly by aforementioned humans well i
think that you can make better designs
and worse designs and i think and you
know the thing about cryptocurrency
that's so interesting
is how many of us
are
responsible for the poor designs because
we're all so hooked
on that horatio alger story on like i'm
gonna be the one who gets the viral
benefit you know
way back when all this stuff was
starting i remember it would have been
in the 80s somebody had the idea of
using viral as a metaphor for network
effect
and the whole point was to talk about
how bad network effect was that it
always created distortions that ruined
the the usefulness of economic
incentives that
that created dangerous distortions like
but then somehow even after the pandemic
we think of viral as this good thing
because we imagine ourselves as the
virus right we want to be on the on the
beneficiary side of it but of course
you're not likely to be
there is a sense because money is
involved people are not reasoning
uh
clearly always because they want to be
they want to be part of that first viral
wave that makes them rich and that
blinds people from their basic morality
i had an interesting conversation i
don't i still feel like i should respect
some people's privacy but some of the
initial people who started uh bitcoin
i i remember having an argument about
like
it's intrinsically a ponzi scheme like
you know the early people have more than
the later people and the further down
the chain you get the more you're
subject to gambling like dynamics where
it's more and more random and more and
more subject to weird network effects
and whatnot
unless you're a very small player uh
perhaps and you're just buying something
but even then you'll be subject to
fluctuations because the whole thing is
just kind of it like that as it
fluctuates it's going to wave around the
little people more and
they i remember the conversation turned
to gambling because gambling's a pretty
large economic sector and it's always
struck me as being
non-productive like somebody goes to las
vegas and they lose money and
so one argument is well they got
entertainment they paid for
entertainment as they lost money so
that's fine and the in las vegas does up
the losing of money in an entertaining
way so why not it's like going to a show
so that's one argument the argument that
was made to me was different from that
it's that no what they're doing is
they're getting a chance to experience
hope and a lot of people don't get that
chance and so that's really worth it
even if they're going to lose they have
that moment of hope and they need to be
able to experience that
and
this is a very interesting argument
um that's so heartbreaking because uh
well
i've seen it but i've seen that like
that i have that a little bit of a sense
i've talked to some young people who
invest in cryptocurrency
and it
what i see is this hope this is the
first thing that gave him hope and
that's so heartbreaking to me
that you've gotten hope from the so much
is invested it's like hope from
somehow becoming rich as opposed to
something to me i apologize but money
is in the long term not going to be a
source of that deep meaning it's good to
have enough money but it should not be
the source of hope
and it's heartbreaking to me how many
people is the source of hope
yeah um
you've just described the psychology of
virality or the psychology of
of trying to base a civilization on
semi-random occurrences of network
effect peaks
you